Disney budvisor target ses entreprises
américaines sont devenues wok pour
séduire les consommateurs mais
aujourd'hui elle le regrette en juin
2020 la célèbre marque l’ego avait
annoncé la suspension de toute promotion
de ces figurines de policiers et le
versement de 4 millions de dollars à des
ONG mutants contre le racisme le but
soutenir le mouvement Black lives matter
qui a émergé après la mort en mai 2020
de Georges Floyd un afro-américain tué
lors de son interpellation par des
policiers blancs dans la foulée
plusieurs grands groupes américains
rejoignent le mouvement mais aujourd'hui
à moins d'un an des élections
présidentielles aux États-Unis certains
d'entre eux sont coincés l'opposition
idéologique entre républicains et
démocrate divisent toujours plus la
société américaine et plusieurs marques
jugées trop progressistes ou trop
conservatrices ont perdu une partie de
leur clientèle exprimée par conv
personnelle sous la pression de groupes
de salariés ou par calcul marketing ces
prises de position devaient placer à peu
de frais les marques dans le camp du
progrès Disney en a fait les frais en
quelques années la marque est passée de
la quatrième à la 77e place des marques
les plus populaires aux États-Unis selon
un classement axiosaris résultat après
des années d'engagement progressistes et
d'opposition au gouverneur conservateur
de Floride Rome De Santis Disney
s'efforce de retrouver un positionnement
plus consensuel le souci de nos pensées
personnes a fini par lasser ses
admirateurs peu sensibles à la nécessité
de tourner une nouvelle version de la
petite sirène avec une actrice noire ou
de censurer les Aristochats jugés
racistes même scénario du côté du
brasseur hanoizer Bush qui vend la très
populaire bière budlight ces ventes ont
chuté de 24% entre avril et juin 2023
après le lancement d'une campagne de pub
en association avec une influenceuse
transgenre autre exemple en juin dernier
la chaîne de supermarché target a dû
retirer de ses rayons des produits
ciblant la communauté LGBT après une
forte vague de boycott qui a pesé sur
son cours en bourse le patron du groupe
c'est alors vu accusé par le gouverneur
démocrate de Californie Gavin neworm de
sacrifier la communauté LGBT aux
extrémistes finalement une grande
majorité des Américains aspirent
aujourd'hui à une forme de neutralité
par exemple 70% se réfavorable au fait
qu'une entreprise limite les
conversations politiques sur le lieu de
travail selon un sondage Aris Paul en
France l'engagement des entreprises sur
des sujets sensibles de société est
aussi un pari risqué mais dans
l'Hexagone le fait religieux serait
plutôt en cause selon les séistes et
real Thévenon sur les sujets de genre ou
d'orientation sexuelle en entreprise ma
crainte et qu'en France le sujet se
déplace et revendications religieuses
pourraient trouver là des fondements et
un relais pour les entreprises qui
étaient parvenues ces dernières années à
apaiser ce terrain le défi s'annonce
rude